I'll begin the class officially,
um,
with a different sort of demonstration.
I want to just show you one of the change
blindness studies that has been done
in the real world
and these videotapes are not available
publicly be get them from the web and see
him as as little javascripts.
So this is a one of the first studies
done by Dan Simons when he was at Cornell
and his advisor at the time,
um, was uh, our friend Kyle,
who's now in our department.
So here's the study
and
you don't notice it. Um, changed.
Linus is one of the more
striking phenomenon discovered
by laboratory scientists
and by site,
by psychologists.
But it's important to realize to get
away from the sort of surprise of the
gorilla and the fact that it's
hard to see the flickering,
the object that's flickering and
appreciate the big moral of this cause.
The big moral of this is actually I
think striking and quite important. Um,
you think right now that you
are perceiving the world.
I looked down on you and I think I have
a whole sense of where everybody is.
I can't see everybody perfectly and back,
you're going to far away and blurry.
But there's a sense in which I,
I have a world around me. Um,
similarly,
if I'm to close my eyes for a second,
everything just remains and I can sort
of remember some of the things that are
there that's really good sound
localization by me. Um, the,
so you're looking up and, and you
think you have a sense of the world,
both in perception and memory,
the change blindness experiments
suggested this isn't true.
The change minus the experiments suggest
that if you look at me for a second,
and during that second,
um,
all of your classmates changed positions,
including those next to you,
you are extremely unlikely to notice
the change blindness experiments suggest
that if you turn your eyes away from me
towards there for a second and turn back
and I'm dressed entirely differently,
you wouldn't notice.
The exceptions would be if
you told yourself consciously,
remember what this guy's wearing?
He's wearing this, that another.
But if you don't do it
consciously, you'll lose it. Um,
and usually this is okay.
Usually it's okay because your memory
and your visual system exploits the basic
fact about the universe,
which is that most things stay the same.
Most of the time I don't
have to explicitly remember
that you're over there when
I turned my head for a second because
you'll be over there in any case,
you don't need to hold precise
representations of the world. Um,
and so you only notice it in
certain clever circumstances.
One sort of clever circumstance is when
psychologists change reality as in a
change blindness studies. A second
sort of circumstance is in movies.
So one of the big surprises when people
started making movies involving cuts was
it is extremely difficult to get
everything continuously right?
And you need to work very hard to notice.
So there's all these continuity errors
that creep up into movies and you have to
be a film buff or writing
it down to even notice this.
And the overall moral here then is that
your perception of reality is a lot more
sparse, a lot more limited
than you might think it is.
So this is where we were
at the end of last class.
We were talking about the different
sorts of memories, um, sensory memory,
which is the sort of fraction
of a second of sensory residue,
what you're hearing and what you're
seeing, working memory, short term memory,
and then longterm memory.
And we talked last class about how
things get into sensory memory,
into working memory,
the role of attention.
And in fact the change blindness
studies are actually just studies of how
something gets from your senses to your
consciousness and what does and what
doesn't. Now I want to move to
distinction in working memory,
short term memory and,
and longterm memory.
Now the obvious distinction
is actually just in fact,
um,
is storage differences.
So longterm memory or Ltm
has a huge storage capacity.
This is your memory,
like the hard drive of your computer.
This is the memory you walk around with.
Um, it includes all the words in English,
just for example, 60, 80,000 words.
It includes everybody you've ever met.
Languages, faces, um, stories, locations,
nursery rhyme, songs, TV programs.
Nobody knows the storage.
It is not true that you remember
everything that has ever happened to you.
That there's no reasonably that this
is true. At the same time though,
you have a huge amount stored in your
brain in longterm storage and nobody
actually, it has to be limited
because it's a finite limited brain,
but nobody knows how big it is.
Nobody knows how many terabytes you
carry around in your brain. And um,
but it's a lot.
Compare this to working memory,
the short term memory,
which is actually very limited.
Your memory of what you could store on
and where you can hold in consciousness
right now is quite limited.
Um, here's an exercise.
Do not write these, these things
down. I want you to remember them.
I'm just going to give you a few numbers.
1459,
11 109-4358-NINETY 848720538954.
Please write them down.
View this as Nike test
if that would relax you.
Okay.
Um,
how many of you who decided to participate
in this experiment got three or less?
Good, good. Um, four, five,
six, seven, eight,
nine or more.
Anybody get all 11?
Um, this is a particularly
difficult memory task.
The numbers are
meaningless and I told him,
and I forgot to tell you to get your
pen and pencil ready so some of you just
glared at me,
but um,
but under normal circumstances,
the cognitive psychologists,
George Miller said that the sort of
suggested that the standard memory storage
of short term memory is
seven plus or minus two.
And what that means is anywhere
from five to nine, roughly,
some of you I bet can beat that.
Some of you on a not so good day,
maybe it won't make it that much.
Um,
now seven plus or minus two is what year?
So that's what you hold in consciousness.
You know, I'm telling you 14,
21 walk around. All right, 1421, you
hold that unconscious, no problem.
But I throw 11 numbers at you.
You can't some dribble out.
You can't hold that in your conscious
window in your short term memory.
Now this raises the question
seven plus or minus two. What?
And the answer seems to be what George
Miller calls chunks and a chunk.
Is it basic memory unit?
Something you think of as
a single individual entity.
Um,
so suppose you see the string of letters,
l a, m, a, I. S. O. N. Um,
if you don't know if you can form these
into words and you have to remember
them, these are eight chunks. You
have to just pick them up separately.
On the other hand,
if you break them up into four words,
you could just remember
that's four chunks.
And if you break it up into two words
in French, uh, Lemay zone, the house,
um,
it could just be one or two.
How much you know,
depends on affects how much you memorize,
how much,
how much you could store in memory,
because it affects what counts
as a basic unit of memory.
And there's all sorts of examples of this.
If I tell you one,
one zero, one, one zero, zero,
one zero, one, one zero, um,
those of you who don't know binary numbers
might have to remember that as one,
one, zero, zero, whatever. I said. Um,
those of you who are computer
scientists or mathematicians,
or for whatever reason,
no binary numbers could convert
into a single binary number.
Anybody know what the number is?
No,
I cannot say it again. Um, some number 24,
not 24 to 224 and then you remember 24,
it's easier.
Suppose you see a chessboard and a Chess
Board is set up and you don't know how
to play chess.
It is murderously hard to remember
that they've done the experiments.
We taking people in the lab who
don't know how to play chess.
They set up a chess board and then they
say, okay, look at this for five minutes.
Looks at it. Then they take it
away, set it up again and it's it.
It's murderously hard.
There was a horsey thing on
the side there and everything.
But if these chess pieces are set up
in some way that's logical for a chess
player,
then a chess master could look at
it and remember it in a glance, oh,
it's the Fibonacci defense or
something like that. Um, and,
and then immediately recover it.
Similarly,
football coaches have been tested on
their memories of football diagrams and
they have like a photographic memory
for football diamonds because it
corresponds to the things that
makes sense. Arik attacks.
Architects could have a photographic
memory of perfect memory for four plants
because it makes sense to
them. They understand it. Um,
and so the way you store things in memory,
and this is a theme we're going to return
to when we get to long term memory,
depends in a large extent on
how much you understand it
and it shows up and expertise affects.
Now
this is what's happening so far in short
term memory, how much you hold in there.
The question is how do you
get it into longterm memory?
So you have longterm memory, your,
your, your major storage system.
How does information get from your
consciousness to longterm storage?
Well,
there's one thing,
there's one way which sort
of works sometimes but not
very well and it's called
maintenance rehearsal.
Suppose I said,
you have to remember this number,
this string of numbers and if you remember
it in 20 minutes you will get $1,000
and a string is the string is my
phone number when I was a kid.
And include the area code (514) 688-9057.
Now if you tell that to it to a four
year old, what four year old said,
I remember it.
And then you asked him what I just say.
Well I don't know if you tell it to
an act cause cause you know something,
if a lot depended on you
would know to do something.
What you would do is
you'd say there's 500,
four (688) 995-7514 (689) 575-1468 you'd
rehearse it in your head over and over
again. The problem is you could
hold it as long as you can do that.
Um, it's like these movies, you see this
all the time, like an episode of 24,
you know, Jack Call Ctu until
them agent 11 is trapped in there.
And I can't even remember this.
But the way to remember that you hold,
you just got to repeat it over
and over again in your head.
But this will not typically get things
into longterm memory to get things in the
longterm memory.
Rehearsal is usually not enough.
You need to do other things.
Typically what you need is
structure and organization.
Okay.
And one way to demonstrate this was
in a class at depth of processing
experiment,
which nicely illustrates the fact that
the more you structure something deeper,
you think about it,
okay?
The better it gets entrenched in
longterm memory. So in this study,
what they did was they asked people,
they told people that there's going to
be words flashed on the screen and all of
the subjects are the same strings
of words. There were 48 words.
They were not told to memorize the words.
Okay?
One third of the subjects was told,
look,
some of these words are going
to come out in capital letters.
Some of them not capital letters, press a
button for capital's non capitals. Sure.
The other group was told,
some of these words will rhyme with train.
Others won't press a button
if it rhymes and train.
The third group was told,
does it fit into the sentence,
the girl placed a blank on
the table, press a button.
If it does, press a button.
If it doesn't,
yeah.
Then they were asked as a surprise.
What words did you see?
And the findings look like this when
they were asked to focus on just what the
word look like,
memory was very poor.
The sound better,
the meaning better.
If you want to remember something,
the best way to remember it is to
give it meaning to give it sense.
Um, this is illustrated through
an a very ancient technique,
which is that the way to remember things
that are otherwise arbitrary is to give
them some organization
through memory tricks,
through vivid imagery or, or, or, um,
songs or poetry.
Um,
and there's a lot of examples of this.
Do you know how to remember that?
The hippocampus, there's part of
your brain called the hippocampus.
This is the worst memory Craig ever,
but it will stick with you for 20 years.
The HIPPA campus is involved
in spatial memory. Um,
it's involved in finding your way around.
Think you yourself.
The way I find my way around
campus is through the hippocampus.
That's stupid.
But you'll never forget now that the
hippocampus is in charge of spatial memory
because we all you retained
from this course, um, memory,
memory books on,
on how to,
on how to remember people's names.
Um,
usually try to exploit this sort of
thing where you try to get poetry are
dramatic images. So that memory books
always typically involve somebody.
Like you meet somebody very spiky
here and they say, my name is Mr Fish.
And then you remember, you think of
they're a big fish and paygov under here.
And then whenever you see them,
you remember their name.
It only really works for
names like fish, but, but the,
but the idea is you try to
generate vivid imagery when stock,
when stuck with a situation where
you have to remember 10 letters,
turn it into a song where are
are, are, are a dirty poem.
What each of the letters is.
The first words of it when having to
remember something that seems totally
arbitrary,
try to figure out
a grant and obscene image that
will come to mind easily. And,
and this is how these are one
way to get things into memory
at a deep level though,
the way to get things into memory,
and this applies to this course
no less than anything else,
is by understanding that understanding.
Again,
I'm going to read you something and I
want you to try your best to remember what
I tell you.
These are not going to be strings
of numbers they use are going to be,
this is going to be a series of sentences,
a newspapers better than a magazine.
A sea shore is a better place
than the street at first.
It is better to run then to walk.
You may have to try several times.
It takes some skill, but it's easy to
learn. Even young children can enjoy it.
One successful complications are minimal.
Bird seldom get to close reign,
however, soaks in very fast.
Too many people doing the same
things can also cause problems.
One needs lots of room. If there are no
complications, that can be very peaceful.
Finally, a rock will serve as an anchor
if things break loose from it. However,
you will not have a second chance.
And here's what I said.
Okay,
this is murderously hard to remember.
Now try it.
Knowing what this is about,
being able to put a context to it
helps the memory and, and, and,
and helps it come to mind.
Okay?
So this is about how to get memory,
how to get information into your memory.
How did you get information out?
So you know,
it's an exam period. You got this
stuff presumably into your head.
You have to get it out. You have to
retrieve it. There's a court case,
you have to figure out. You have to
recount the crime that you witnessed.
Um,
you see somebody and you want to know
his or her name and you heard it.
You just have to get it out.
Well, how do you do that? Well,
here's the retrieval cues.
Retrieval cues makes sense.
Retrieval cues are just things that,
that have been associated with what
you, um, what you're trying to remember?
MMM.
If I,
if I have to remember to
replace the windows when I
walk into my living room and
see that a window is cracked, that will
remind me to replace the windows. If, if,
um, if I had a lunch date with you
and forgot about it when I see you.
Oh yeah. We were supposed to
get together and have lunch. Um,
retrieval cue is bring things back,
but it's a little bit more complicated
in that there's a more general
relationship between encoding
and retrieval call the
compatibility principle.
And what this means is you're much better
to remember something in the context
in which you have learnt it.
And this is also known as
context dependent memory
and state dependent memory.
It's illustrated by one of the
strangest experiments in the history of
psychology where they had people on a
boat and then they had them scuba dive
underwater and they taught them things
either on the boat or underwater,
like with things that they held up.
And then they tested them later and uh,
turns out that you'll remember it better
if you're tested on it in the context
in which you learn it.
And it might be because then the
retrieval cues help bring it back. Um,
but it's more general in that if you
have to remember something you learned in
this class,
you will do better.
If you try to think about the
room in which you learned at it,
you will do better on your final exam
if you were to take it in this room than
if you were to take it in another room.
Because being in this room,
we'll bring back the cues.
It's not just the environment.
People will learn things
when they're stoned.
Remember them better keeping
stone that is sort of a low level.
It doesn't disrupt
other mental activities.
Remember them better when
they're sort of stone again
then after non stone.
Similarly. So, you know,
if you study while you drink,
you should typically a little bit
before coming into the final exam.
It's sort of like what happens in Vegas,
stays in Vegas, sort of results. Um,
and so similarly,
it even applies to moods in that if you
learn something when depressed used to
have a slightly better recovery of
it when you're in that same mood of
depression than when you're elated.
And the idea is that part of what
memory is part of recovering memories is
getting back your original context
in which you've learned it.
Um,
elaborative rehearsal and retrieval a
lot involves the connections between
different things.
Um,
elaborative rehearsal is that the
more you think about something,
the easier it is to remember.
If you have to think about,
if you have to remember something,
try to connect it to as many things
as possible. Think of an image,
make a joke out of it. Imagine how
you would explain it to somebody else.
Um, imagine how the world, what the
world will be like if it wasn't. So,
and the idea is that this sort of thinking
about it makes connections in your
memory from that thing you have to learn
to other memories and so it makes it
easier to recover.
Um,
elaborative retrieval
refers to a finding that,
um, when you want to get
something back at a memory,
people tend to give up too soon.
It turns out that there's a lot
of stuff that's in your memory,
but it needs work to extract.
It needs various sort of
searching strategies. Um,
one study asks people,
um,
who were considerably older than you to
remember their high school classmates.
And in the first pass people are terrible.
Maybe they had a couple of friends they
kept in touch with otherwise pretty bad.
And this is a good experiment because
you could use high school yearbooks to
judge whether or not they get it right.
But then what you do is you tell the
person, look, keep trying. Um, where you,
what sort of, who is your teacher?
What sort of clubs that you belong to?
What sort of sports did you participate
in? How did you get to school?
How did you get from school? Um, what
did you do during lunch? What did you do?
Or during break. And You keep asking,
you know, have any friends whose letter,
whose last name began with B with C,
with D,
and you keep pushing and pushing and
pushing and over the span of time,
things come back again.
It's not true that you never forget.
There is honest to God, forget it.
But sometimes you think you forget as,
because you haven't looked long enough.
There's a real physical notion of
searching for the right answer.
We've talked about retrieval.
Oh, every class I've given,
somebody asks either in class or by email.
What about Deja Vu?
And Deja Vu is a feeling that
an event has happened before.
So you're looking at me and I'm lecturing.
He said, I've heard this before. No,
I know this before you see somebody and
say, I've been in a situation before.
This is not evidence for psychic powers.
Um,
which many people say it is,
but nobody really knows why this exists.
We know,
and this is a clue.
It's worse with frontal lobe damage.
You get damaged as part of the brain.
You get a lot more deja Vu experiences.
I asked some experts in memory,
um, including Marsha Johnson,
who's chair of our department,
what the best explanation for Deja Vu is.
And the answer she gave the one
big theory goes like this. Um,
Deja Vu is a feeling
that has happened before.
The answer is it has happened before.
It's happened half a second ago.
And so what happens is
sometimes there's a glitch.
Yeah,
a disturbance in the force.
I don't know if there's a glitch and you
were talking and then something happens
to you and you put it in your memory.
But it's as if you don't put the stamp
on it of what time and what date.
So you're talking to me and
then you store it in memory,
but you don't store it in
memory as happening right now.
Then have a second goes by and
you're talking to me. He says,
this is strangely familiar
and that's one theory of what
goes on in Deja Vu. Okay.
So far. Does this sort of good news
remembering? But then there's bad news.
Forgetting
how many people can remember
without looking down at your notes.
At least two of the
numbers I gave you earlier.
Okay.
How many people can remember
at least four. Oh, impressive.
Um, if I asked you in an hour,
the number would go down.
These are sort of statistics in a similar
experiment in this graph illustrates
that people forget over time,
you'll forget.
Why do you forget? Why is
there forgetting at all? Well,
there's different explanations for this.
One explanation is your
brain is a physical thing.
It's a physical piece of meat and
a kind of goes bad physical decay.
And so the memory traces that are laid
onto your brain will just decay over time.
The second answer is interference.
So remember those numbers.
Here's a few more.
Hundred and 1480160640 two.
Well, the more information that comes
in at similar to stuff you're trying to
remember,
it blocks your recovery
of original information.
So your ability to remember something
can be impaired by learning more things
which are related to it because
they get confused in memory.
Finally, and maybe this is
most interesting, there are
changes in retrieval cues.
So the more time goes by,
the more the world changes.
And if your memory is to some extent
dependent on qs bringing it back to life,
then um,
the change in retrieval cues,
okay.
Can make it more difficult to,
um, to recall certain things.
This leads to a puzzle where there's
considerable scientific debate over the
case of Childhood Amnesia.
And the case of Childhood Amnesia is,
um,
it doesn't refer to when a child
gets brain damage. You Guys Amnesia,
whatever refers to is people have a
difficult time recovering very early
memories.
I want people to just take a second and
try to think back on what your first
memory is and roughly how old you were.
Okay.
How many people don't think you have a
first memory until you were about five
years old or older.
Okay.
How many people think you have a first
memory of around age four or younger?
memory of around age three or younger?
Two or younger?
Yeah.
How many of you think you have a first
memory when you were about one years old
or younger?
Okay.
And I'm not asking about past lives that,
that had happened last year.
Um, how, how, how old is your
roughly your first memory, you think
how old
between one and two.
Anybody think they can beat that
same guy?
Yep.
One.
Anybody else?
MMM.
The literature is unclear on this because
it's very difficult to test people's
recollections of their first memories.
If I'm to ask people about your first
memories, they'll often say, oh yeah,
I remember I was in this room and there
was a crib and I going to gag a Gugu
and, um, I was on a potty.
I was, I was walking,
I was so cute. I remember it.
It's very difficult to tell.
And as we'll discuss in some detail,
there are a lot of reasons
to distrust people when they,
not that they're lying, but to distress,
to accuracy of people's memories.
We also know from studies about trauma
where people have terrible experiences
when there are one or two. Typically this
trauma is not men remembered later on.
People know of trauma because
you're told about it. Um,
but they don't typically remember
with any accuracy. Even children,
older children don't remember
back beyond that age.
Nobody knows why Childhood Amnesia occurs.
Nobody knows why.
It's very difficult to recover
memories before about the age of three.
One theory is that the
retrieval cues change radically.
I had a friend of mine who's a clinical
psychologist and he suggested a new form
of therapy where they make these giant
tables and chairs and then they bring you
into the office and you're standing at
the giant tables and chairs and all these
memories of being a baby would
come flooding back. And uh, he,
he dropped out at the
field. And really, um,
but it's such a cool idea. Um, some
people think language is to blame.
So a child,
a baby starts out with no
spoken or sign language.
Language comes to be learned
at around one, two and three.
And it might be that the learning of a
language reformat your memory and once
the memory is reformatted,
it can't go back to the previous
state prior to language.
In the end, it could be neuro maturation.
It could be that there's memory,
parts of the brains grow around age two
or three that just weren't there prior
to that and nobody really knows.
It's a,
it's a fascinating research area.
Why about memory changes early on?
Another case of memory
failure is brain damage
and brain damage comes in.
A couple of flavors.
There is retrograde Amnesia Retro for
past Retrograde Amnesia is when you lose
some memory of the past.
This could be in a case where you get
some sort of head trauma and you lose
memory of your entire episodic memory,
but typically if you have any sort of
serious accident involves you losing
consciousness,
you'll have a blackout of some period
prior to that say bloated ahead.
And the reason for this is as you're
having these experiences now they need to
kind of get,
get consolidated into your brain.
The brain needs to rewire and catch up
to the experiences you're having a sudden
bloated ahead,
we'll knock you unconscious and then
the memories have happened immediately
prior. Well not get consolidated
and there'll be lost forever.
Another sort of memory is
anterior grade amnesia.
And this was the case of this
happens and causes a cough syndrome.
It happens to a very famous patient known
as h m who actually lives in Hartford,
Connecticut.
Um,
and it happened to Clive wearing
the film you saw last class.
And this as heard of Amnesia is a sort
of Amnesia where you lose the abilities
to form new memories.
And so you live in a perpetual present,
unable to accumulate new memories,
but it's actually a little bit
more complicated than that.
What happens is,
and this was an exciting discovery about
these patients that led to some real
insights about normal memory.
What happens is,
and this is the brain
damage in these cases,
the temporal lobe and the hippocampus,
very useful for spatial memory.
You'll know when discovery made about
people who couldn't form new memories is
that they could form new memories.
But if certain types,
so for example, this is a
task care involving, um,
filling in a star while looking into
a mirror. And if I asked you to do,
you'd find it pretty difficult.
It's just kind of difficult to do.
You'd be clumsy at it.
You bring in an amnesic who can't
form new memories and you say, Hey,
I want you to try something new. I want
you to try this star game. Say, okay,
I've never seen it before, but I'll
do it. Tries it does very badly.
You bring him in over and over again.
Each time he does it,
he starts off by saying,
I've never seen this before.
I'll, I'm sure I'll give it a try.
But he gets better and better at it.
And this is known as implicit memory.
The claim is that in these sorts of cases,
you lose the abilities to form explicit
conscious memories that you're aware of,
that you understand,
but some sorts of memories persist
and you are able to form them.
Um,
this is actually been illustrated
in a couple of dramatic movies.
One of them are very bad
dramatic movie. Um, where, uh,
drew Barrymore loses the ability to form
new memories and somehow falls in love
with Adam Sandler.
Definitely don't watch that,
but a very good movie called Memento,
which is about a character who loses
his ability to form new memories.
While trying to track down his
wife's killer memento is a movie,
which is fascinating because it's told
backwards. But through my mentors,
it's another story told forwards.
And I like this story because it very
dramatically illustrates what does and
what what is and is not
impaired in, um, in,
in cases of severe memory damage.
So I'm going to show you a couple of clips
that illustrate the dissociation from
Momento.
Those have you seen the movie knows,
know that this ends up quite
tragically for Sammy. Um,
you recommend a movie.
We've,
we've dealt right now with two
sorts of failures of memory.
One is every day failure
of memory when you forget.
How many of you remember three are more
of the numbers I originally presented?
Yeah,
go ahead.
1459, 11. Is that right?
Fine.
I'm going to ask you again in a month.
Um,
well people are supposed to forget. Um,
and some things will, you will forget.
That's normal.
Forgetting a second case is I'm forgetting
due to brain damage for getting due
to brain damage is exotic and unusual.
Um,
but it's interesting and that illustrates
some of the more general themes about
how the mind works.
Remember,
one theme of this course is we're going
to look at exotic cases like the case of
Clive wearing,
um,
not just because they're
interesting in their own rights,
but sometimes by looking at the extremes,
we can learn something about
how normal people's normal,
intact minds and brains work.
The third case of forgetting is
more interesting and it actually,
well,
I want to do a little trial here.
What I want to do is I want you
to hit listen to three children.
Describe an event that happened.
I want you to come to some your own gas.
Imagine you were a judge,
you were a child care worker.
You want it to be, I want you
to do become to your own guests.
But who you believe and
what you think happened.
You've heard three children.
Who Do you believe?
Who believes? There's three of them? One,
two, three. Who believes the first one?
Yeah.
Who believes? The second one?
Who believes the third one?
Sort of an even split.
MMM.
2100 experts were shown
these films and asked, um,
about the different actions,
whether or not the person ripped
the book messed up the bear,
tossed the book in the air.
Um, and as you can see,
the majority thought that they did.
Um,
this is, uh, work done
by a Steve CC who was gracious enough to,
um,
to lend me the film to
use for teaching purposes.
It turns out the second girl was right.
Absolutely nothing happened.
Um, the teacher said there's
somebody named Sam Stone.
He's going to come in.
Guy Walks in, says hi,
walks around and leaves
the first and third children had
their memories implanted. Um,
not through any sort of science fiction
means they had their memories implanted.
Well,
they had memories implanted it like this.
Some of the children were just ask
questions. The interviewer, by the way,
was herself unaware of what happened.
So the interview was a
perfectly naive interviewer. Um,
and it turns out if you just interview
children and you ask them questions about
whether the book was ripped, did
you see him? Did he really do it?
They don't say anything. They didn't
see anything and he won't say anything.
Other children were told about Sam stone.
They were told a
stereotype about Sam stone,
that he's very clumsy and he tends to
rip things and he trips and he breaks
things and he spills things.
And in fact,
the third child mentioned that in
passing. He said he always does that. Um,
just knowing this about Sam stone tends
to raise the proportion of kids who say
for instance,
that he ripped the book.
Other children were given suggestions.
They were given suggestive questioning.
They were, um, a series of
leading questions like, oh,
Sam stone came in,
did he rip a book while he was there?
And still more children got both.
And in fact,
the children he used saw
were from this group.
They heard Sam stone being described as
a clumsy fellow and they were given a
series of suggestive
questionings in this condition.
They were given several
suggestive questionings over
a period of several months.
These children, like the first
child, the third child are not lying.
They honestly believe that Sam
stone came in and did these things.
Also they believe it and they're so
convincing in their belief that experts,
including police officers and child
caseworkers and judges and lawyers find
these children to be extremely believable.
And I think they probably find them
to be extremely believable because the
children are not blind. They really
believe they saw what they saw.
But these memories were an implanted and
cc and many other investigators study
how memories can be implanted in people's
minds through suggestion and through
leading questions.
It turns out that the same
sort of experiment and same
sort of research has been
done with considerable success in an
planting false memories in adults.
Um,
there are dramatic cases of
people remembering terrible
crimes and confessing to
them when actually they
didn't commit them.
And this is not because,
um,
they are lying is not even because
they're in some obvious sense the range or
schizophrenia or delusional rather they
have persuaded themselves are more often
been persuaded by others that these
things have actually happened.
Psychologists have studied in the
laboratory how one could do this,
how one can implant memories
in other people. Um,
and some things are sort of standard.
Suppose I was to tell you a story about
a trip I took to the dentist or a visit
I took to our time when I ate out at
a restaurant and I'm to omit certain
details like I omit the fact that I
paid the bill in a restaurant. Say, oh,
I finished a meal and then I went home.
Still you'll tend to fill in the blanks.
You'll tend to fill in the
blanks with things you know.
So you might remember this later saying,
Oh yeah, he told me he finished eating,
paid the bill and left cause paying
the bills. What you do in a restaurant,
this is benign and enough if
you fill in the blanks, um,
you also
can integrate suppositions made by others.
And the clearest case of this
is eye witness testimony.
And the best research on this has been
done by Elizabeth Loftus who has an a
series of studies,
some discussed in a textbook showing
how people's memories can be swayed by
leading questions.
And it can be extremely subtle.
In one experiment,
the person was just asked in the course
of a series of questions shown a scene
where there's a car accident and as either
did you see a broken headlight or did
you see the broken headlight?
The,
the pre supposes there was a
broken headlight and in fact,
the people told as did you see the broken
headlight later on are more likely to
remember? One, it creates an
image and they fill it in. Um,
in another study, uh, she would
show film segments and then ask,
did you see the children getting on a
school bus? Now there was no school bus,
but people who hear that
question later on when asked,
did you see a school bus in the
film are more likely to say yes.
In another study,
she would show people film segments and
asked them either how fast were the cars
going when they hit each other,
or how fast were the cars going
when they smashed into each other.
A week later, she bring people
back into the laboratory and ask,
did you see any broken glass?
Those who hear smash tend to see the
broken glass more than those who hear hit
because the question has
changed their memory.
Making it more of a dramatic event
have knows us as the clearest case.
Where, um, where does the sort
of reconstructive effort led by,
um, led as a result of
leading and probing questions?
Um,
some of you are readily hypnotizable
and you can be hypnotized.
And what we would learn
about a past event, um,
from hypnotizing you will not
necessarily been be inaccurate.
What hypnotizing does is it makes
people very willing to cooperate. Um,
unfortunately it isn't as if there's a
memory storage there where you could just
go through and look as in the
movies where you just say,
what's the license plate?
The person is hypnotized.
And then the flashback comes in in
the zoom in on the license plate.
Memory doesn't work that way.
What happens is what somebody will do in
hypnotizable status that we very eager
to please the hypnotist.
And so it will make stuff up and people
under hypnosis just make stuff up and
they do very enthusiastically,
um,
and very believably make stuff up.
This is particularly the case
with hypnotic regression.
When we ask you to go back to your
sixth birthday party for instance,
and what's great as a developmental
psychologist is if I ask you to go back to
your fourth birthday party
and you're hypnotizable,
you'll be all just like a four year old,
except you won't be like
a real four year old.
Where you'll be like is an adult's notion
of what a four year old is supposed to
be. Um, in fact,
this has happened in the extreme case
with hypnotic regression where people
claim to speak a language is like from,
from ancient Egypt.
And linguists love these studies
because then you don't, of course,
you don't really sound like
you're speaking a language
from ancient Egypt where
you sound is uh,
like a North American who believes he's
speaking a language from ancient Egypt
over right there.
I got her for that.
And so what it makes you is it hidden.
It is and brings out the actor in you.
It makes you want to give a
persuasive account of what happened.
And so hypnotism is just an extreme form
of what normally happens in eyewitness
testimony.
Repressed memories.
We could devote a class,
we could devote a semester to the very
heated debate in the United States,
mostly about repressed memories.
There are many adults who have claimed
to have experienced traumatic sexual
abuse. Um, in some cases,
this is unexceptional from
a memory point of view.
People know this happened to them.
They've always known it happens to them,
and then they tell people about it.
But there's a subset of cases where
people have had no memory up to a point of
what happened to them. Then they go
to a psychologist or a psychiatrist,
they undergo questioning,
um,
often using hypnotic techniques and then
they recover a memory of past traumatic
sexual abuse.
And what,
this is what makes us so debatable
and there is a debate about this.
I don't want to try to
preclude it one way or another.
What makes us debatable is
some psychologists believe
that at least some cases
these memories are real and they have
been repressed through a Freud he and
mechanism that there are two terrible to
bring to consciousness and the therapy
brings them out into real life.
But most psychologists believe that
these memories could not be trusted,
that these memories are created
through the actions of the therapists.
Um,
and so there's actually a considerable
psychological and legal battles over the
voracity of the therapist where women
who have claimed to have sexual be
sexually abused for instance,
have press criminal charges against her
father's on the basis of false memories.
Similarly,
people who have been accused of sexual
abuse have press criminal charges against
psychiatry address claiming that these
psychiatrists have implanted the memories
into their sons and daughters.
It is controversial whether
memories are ever repressed.
What isn't controversial is that for at
least some cases you can implant false
memories in people.
Not because you're a sinister evil person,
but because you really believe something
happened and you talk to them about it
and then you cause these
memories to come into being
a final case is flashbulb memories.
I asked us early in the semester,
I'll ask it again.
How many of you remember where
you were in September 11th, 2001
there anybody who doesn't remember
where they were in September 11th,
2001 it would be interesting because
it's socially relevant event.
Um, but here's the problem
with these flashbulb memories.
Flashbulb memories aren't idea that these
memories being so vivid and they are
vivid for many of us. Exactly
where we stood, what happened. Um,
well they can't really be
trusted and here's why.
Not because they're such important events.
I bet many of you have actually
heard the question before,
where were you on September
11th and talked about it.
What happens in these
conversations is stories change.
I have my event, I knew where
I was on September 11th,
my wife knew where she was,
but I spent as much time listening to
her talk about it as I spent time me
talking about it.
And now maybe my memory is actually
of her experience and not mine.
It's not for all of these cases.
The temptation you have
to resist is saying, yes,
I know memories can be swayed.
I know they could be distorted everything,
but you see,
I really am sure that happened.
You have to resist that temptation
because there are so many cases we know,
including the tape of the girls that we
just saw where people aren't entirely
sure things happen and we know
full well that they didn't exist.
Being sure is no guarantee that a
memory isn't false reconstructed or even
implanted. So this part of
memory has three made morals.
There are many types of memories.
I talked about short term memory,
long term memory. I talked about
implicit memory and explicit memory. Um,
these are sort of
separable sort of memories.
You could break one while
having the other one impaired.
Arguably there assist rain systems.
Um,
dedicated to memory for faces,
memory for everyday objects,
memory for spatial locations.
Um,
the key to remembering his
organization and understanding
introduction,
introduction to x courses
including introduction to
psychology courses are among
the hardest courses at Yale.
And the reason why is there's
just a lot of material, um,
that that is diverse and you have
to command each aspects separately.
The easiest courses at Yale tend to be
high Falutin seminars where you kind of
have enough of a background that
everything is going to be clear and
understandable. Um, the more
you understand something,
the easy or easier you'll remember it.
And finally you can't trust
some of your memories.
Um,
your reading response for this week
is, um, you have to use your
powers for good and not for evil.
Um, though, if you managed to succeed
at this, I will be very impressed.
But you have to,
you have to describe it based on the
lecture materials and the readings,
how to implant a false memory.
MMM.
We have a few minutes. Any,
any questions on memory?
Yes.
You play music.
Hey,
please.
Yeah.
Is that like
the example is, what sort of memory is
it when you know how to play the piano?
It's a very good question.
It is long term memory because you might
know how to do a concerto or a song and
if you have it stored in your head,
you carry it around with you.
You'll remember it a from now two
years from now. It is longterm memory,
but it is also an excellent example of
implicit memory because you know how to
do it. But, but you could do it
unconsciously. You Vet attendings,
it's as it's not century,
but it's as if put a crudely that
your fingers now and not your mind.
We have time for one more question.
Yes.
The question is about photographic memory.
Um,
there are a lot of claims
about photographic memory.
My understanding is they do
not tend to be substantiated.
Sometimes photographic memory,
and this came up when we talked about
autism a few classes ago is linked with
savant like skills.
People have severe impairments in some
ways may have photographic memories in
others.
I am not convinced that photographic
memory in a sense that you see something,
you take a picture of it, you
hold in memory really exists. Um,
I think there may be one or two case
studies that suggested might be real,
but I think it's controversial. Okay. Um,
we have a guest lecture on
Wednesday. Uh, Dean Peter Salivate.
We'll talk to us about love.